yeah welcome to this video playing who's
on whose am from Uruguay the plate I
tried okay come on I can I can take this
playing the the leather bra at the b3
the last opening I had recently some
sperience are on them on the black side
and I thought that it wasn't so um so
bad for white so let's give it a go
yeah I want to ideally I want him to
take on c4 or allow me to take so he
will have a pawn at the end on b3 some
exchanges yeah well this is this looks
looks like a nice a nice structure it's
got a weaker porn I wonder probably yeah
probably i should do that prevent mc5 oh
this is so this is surprising or maybe
not see for bas better
mmm yeah well sir
it's a funny position so what does he go
black look at the position you can
hardly move the thing is can he can he
go for some some some weird technical
stuff Queen somewhere Queen a five maybe
a queen 85 as a good move yeah he needs
to exchanges Queens I mean I'm probably
just winning because he doesn't have any
counter play I can just pick off all the
pawns and if he moves the Queen earth
god I've got Queen to c7 rights it's
early but it's probably probably through
the right assessment yeah well if it
takes just just for starters he loses b7
and c6 this is this is completely
unplayable and if you go here i have my
idea what's Quincy seven but he's
threatening night c5 so maybe I need to
need to improve a bit maybe this stuff
like that I'm threat i'm i'm i'm
covering i but i don't i don't must
avoid to play Queen system while resins
was too early I actually thought I would
be would be even better but I mean it is
it is very very bad for black he cannot
move but it's a bit early to to resign
the game of course it was some this all
vente far down hill to to a structure
that is really good good for wide here
but the problem is what is the
alternative of Hume I mean the
alternative is better than taking but if
you play let's say here why would
exchange and then you've got this t5
weakness and
this is a problem long term as the d5
pawn can be attacked by all pieces okay
the night on d 2 is some moves a way to
do that but you know something like this
and all pieces can attack d 5 but the f8
bishop cannot defend it so you have a
long-term problem now with your booty
porn structure but it's not fatal you
shouldn't shouldn't necessarily lose the
game is just a very uncomfortable
position at here is on it resides really
too early here alright thanks for
watching